[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers hallo und
guten abend in allen an einem tag der
mit vielen milliarden euro daher kommt
geld das man sich nicht wirklich
vorstellen kann geld das wir nicht haben
geld das sich der staat leiden muss der
wirtschafts und der finanzminister haben
heute einen schutzschild für unternehmen
vorgestellt die unter den folgen des
krieges in der ukraine leiden und an den
hohen energiepreisen
das motto dabei klingt ein wenig nach
dem in der finanzkrise whatever it takes
es klingt auch ein wenig nach pfeifen im
wald ich habe gleich fragen an den
finanzminister aber erst guckt thomas
reichert auf gewaltige zahlen bei gleich
einer ganzen reihe von hilfspaketen
es sind die erschütterungen von
russlands krieg gegen die ukraine die
berlin bis spät wach halten und der
versuch eben diese erschütterungen
irgendwie aufzufangen letzten acht es
geht um die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
der bund verspricht kurz vor mitternacht
ländern und kommunen 2 milliarden euro
um die vertriebenen zu unterstützen wir
haben damit die grundlage dafür
geschaffen dass langfristig unser land
zusammenstehen kann und sich auf die
konkrete aufgabe der hilfeleistung und
der integration konzentrieren kann statt
institutionen miteinander zu streiten
am nächsten morgen wieder geht es um die
folgen des krieges diesmal wegen der
gestiegenen preise sollen die bürger
weniger steuern zahlen dafür sollen
erhöht werden der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag der
grundfreibetrag und früher als geplant
die pendlerpauschale wir wollen sich
schnell und unbürokratisch entlasten wir
helfen vor allem den haushalten die in
besonderer weise von herzen getroffen
sind habe die mittel seien endlich so
lindner die opposition aber findet die
hilfen reichen nicht während wir hier
diskutieren steigt die inflation nicht
nur die gefühlte und entwertet meine
damen und herren ihre entlastung spec
von der koalition mittags dann noch
einmal geht es um den schutz vor
erschütterungen lindner und habe
kündigen hilfen für unternehmen an
das was wir als paket ihnen vorstellen
ist ein wirtschaftspolitischer
stoßdämpfer er
federt herten ab verhindert struktur
brüche ein stoßdämpfer für kriegsfolgen
un-sanktionen finanz und
wirtschaftsministerium stellen
unternehmen dafür viele milliarden euro
bereit geplant sind ein kostenzuschuss
für energieintensive betriebe volumen
rund fünf milliarden euro kredite der
förderbank kfw für firmen die in
zahlungsschwierigkeiten geraten über 7
milliarden
kapitalhilfen und garantien für
unternehmen die an energie börsen
handeln bis zu 100 milliarden was ist
nicht schafft noch einmal das muss man
einfach in der härte und ehrlichkeit
sagen ist die totale kostenübernahme
durch den staat wir müssen in dieser
zeit alle ein teil tragen die frage ist
wie groß ist der teil und die kann man
es gerecht hinbekommen diesmal also
nicht die besucher die zu beginn der
pandemie möglichst vielen viel helfen
sollte er schon begrenzte hilfen für
betriebe die besonders unter hohen
energiekosten leiden notwendig ist
allerdings dass das paket schnell kommt
dass es unbürokratisch ist und dass es
unmittelbar den unternehmen hilft dann
werden wir auch unseren beitrag dazu
leisten können das zu unterstützen
dankeschön es ging an diesem tag viel
ums helfen flüchtlingen bürgern
unternehmen und am ende auch darum wie
nahe die beben von putins krieg
deutschland längst gekommen sind
es gibt ja ein in der vergangenheit
bereits angewandtes politisches anti
krisen mittel und das heißt koste es was
es wolle also geld raushauen sag ich
jetzt mal salopp weil allein die
ankündigung bereits für ruhe sorgt und
weitere panik in der wirtschaft
vermeiden guten abend an den
bundesfinanzminister und talent nach
einen schönen guten abend ist dass ihre
taktik aktuell
nein ganz im gegenteil
wir haben eine andere lage als bei der
korona pandemie wir haben einzelne
branchen die sehr stark betroffen sind
von den steigenden energiepreisen
unter den leidet die wirtschaft
insgesamt aber in einigen branchen ist
es eine gefährdung der existenz und was
wir jetzt vorgelegt haben ist nicht ein
was auch immer es kostet sondern es ist
eine art stoßdämpfer
zeitlich befristet und sehr
zielgerichtet werden wir die wirtschaft
unterstützen damit arbeitsplätze
erhalten bleiben und damit es nicht zu
struktur brüchen kommt aber wir können
nicht allgemein steigende preise
ausgleichen auf dauer das heißt das
signal ist nicht der start fängt uns auf
das wäre ja auch ein psychologisches
pfund ich glaube das wäre ein sehr
klares signal senden nämlich dass wir
jetzt dafür sorgen dass es nicht zu
dauerhaften schäden und struktur brüchen
kommt aber wir können der tatsache nicht
ausweichen dass wir insgesamt neue
quellen für unseren wohlstand und unser
wachstum in deutschland brauchen es ist
nicht mehr die importierte günstige
energie sondern wir brauchen wieder neu
einfallsreichtum unternehmergeist
leistungs freude also
marktwirtschaftliche tugenden um
wohlstand und wachstum zu sichern
nur für die übergangszeit da brauchen
wir jetzt instrumente wie die die robert
habeck und ich vorgelegt haben herr
länder versuchen wir uns das doch mal
vorzustellen das ist ja nicht ganz
einfach diese enormen summen wenn dieses
jahr die schuldenbremse gelten würde
dann wären maximal 13 milliarden euro
schulden erlaubt tatsächlich sind sie
jetzt bereits bei krediten die sie
aufnehmen wollen von
224 milliarden euro da sehen wir so ein
bisschen die relation des ganzen die fdp
hat den damaligen finanzminister olaf
scholz mal schuldenkönig genannt das
sind jetzt sie oder ich muss die zahl
etwas korrigieren da sind die 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr mit drin
das sogenannte sondervermögen bundeswehr
das gelände seit anfang der bundeswehr
wenn ich sehr kurz unterbrechen hat ist
ja am ende extra schulden für java darum
aber das will ich ihnen gar nicht
ausreden ich will nur sagen dass das
nicht geld ist was wir dieses jahr
aufnehmen sondern es wird jetzt verbucht
aber die schulden werden nicht dieses
jahr kassenwirksam dennoch haben sie
recht sie haben recht
aufgrund der nicht bewältigten corona
pandemie aufgrund der veränderten
geopolitischen risiken stichworte
bundeswehr und aufgrund jetzt des
wirtschaftlichen schocks aufgrund der
steigenden energiepreise und da damit
notwendigen entlastungen für die bürger
für die privaten haushalte und für die
wirtschaft nehmen wir enorme
verbindlichkeiten auf sie dürfen mir
glauben die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
dürfen mir glauben das mache ich nicht
gerne und leichtfertig wir achten darauf
dass wir nur das an verbindlichkeiten
aufnehmen was wirklich notwendig ist
aber so ist eben die lage es wäre nicht
verantwortlich nichts zu tun die
menschen mit steigenden preisen alleine
zu lassen oder auf dauer arbeitsplätze
zu verlieren nächstes jahr wollen sie
die schuldenbremse wieder einhalten
haben sie bislang immer gesagt einfach
nur weil es gut klingt denn realistisch
ist das ja nicht
das sagen sie es ist nun übrigens auch
kein politischer wille oder absicht die
da zählen sondern es ist ein gebot ein
befehl sogar unserer verfassung und
deshalb achte ich ja darauf dass wir
jetzt in der krise handlungsfähig sind
dass wir aber alles unternehmen um im
nächsten jahr zur normalität der
staatsfinanzen zurückzukehren wenn es
keine außergewöhnliche katastrophale
situation in der wirtschaft gibt dann
ist das auch unsere
verfassungsrechtliche verpflichtung und
wir müssen es tun denn jede milliarde
die wir aufnehmen müssen die bürgerinnen
und bürger die steuerzahlen der stadt in
den nächsten jahren tilgen das stimmt
sie müssen es tun die frage ist nur ob
sie es tun können sie sagen sie rechnen
nicht mit einer katastrophalen situation
in der wirtschaft aber das kann man doch
überhaupt nicht sagen wir wissen ja im
moment nicht mal wie lange der krieg in
der ukraine noch geht
gegenwärtig haben wir noch eine prognose
für wachstum sogar für das jahr
deshalb sollten wir doch bitte darauf
hoffen dass wir nicht wie in den
pandemie jahren und jetzt in diesem jahr
aufgrund des ukraine kriegs in
deutschland eine solche ausnahme
situation haben wir haben große
herausforderungen wir haben allerdings
auch vorsorgen getroffen in klima und
transformations- von den wir nutzen
können gewisse rücklagen die ich zur
verfügung habe mein ziel ist jedenfalls
klar in der krise handeln aber
schnellstmöglich zurück zu stabilen
nachhaltig soliden staatsfinanzen in
unser aller interesse ein ziel und auch
eine menge hoffnung dabei kristalliner
der bundesliga ambitionen wieder dank
für das gespräch herr lindner
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen am abend aufgezeichnet
mit dem zug unterwegs auf einer mission
die auch die dienstreise erfahrene
ursula von der leyen so schnell nicht
vergessen wird die eu kommissionschef in
ist nach kiew gefahren durch zerstörte
orte zum gespräch mit einem präsidenten
der sein land so schnell wie möglich in
die europäische union bringen will und
dem gast aus brüssel ein versprechen
abnimmt florian hahn hat mehr
da liegen die leichen in schwarze
plastiksäcke verpackt bis vor kurzem in
einem massengrab verscharrt jetzt sollen
ermittler klären was genau hier passiert
ist zuerst aber kommt die politik ursula
von der leyen chefin der eu kommission
an dem auf der zum symbol geworden ist
für die brutalität dieses krieges
butscher von der leyen die für
gewöhnlich alles hinter einer maske des
lächelns versteckt ist der schock
anzusehen
hier in butter ist die menschlichkeit
zerstört worden die ganze welt trauert
mit den menschen von buschehr
die reise beginnt am abend zuvor an der
polnischen grenze dort wo immer noch
tausende geflüchtete pro tag ankommen
und sie wird begleitet von einer frage
ist das hier nur ein symbol das die
antwort darauf nein lautet dafür sorgt
der mann links neben von der leyen
eduard heber ministerpräsident der
slowakei dennoch im zug nach kiew eine
videobotschaft aufnimmt
ich kann bestätigen dass die slowakei
der ukraine das luftabwehrsystem s-300
geschenkt hat
das slowakische
verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
kurz darauf diese bilder die zeigen
sollen wie die luftabwehr in die ukraine
geschickt wird
auch ursula von der leyen hätte gern so
handfestes mit im gepäck als sie später
in kiew den ukrainischen präsidenten wie
lenz am trifft und so verspricht die
seinem land ein beschleunigtes verfahren
zur aufnahme in die eu
russland wird in den wirtschaftlichen
finanziellen und technologischen verfall
abgleiten während die ukraine in eine
europäische zukunft marschiert european
future dabei kann die
kommissionspräsidentin gar keine zusagen
machen über einen eu beitritt
entscheiden die mitgliedstaaten genauso
wie über die sanktionen die ihr
gastgeber anspricht ja wo ihr aber ich
danke der europäischen union ursula von
der leyen ich bedanke mich persönlich
für das fünfte sanktionspaket dennoch
finde ich dass es zu wenig ist
ursula von der leyen will ein zeichen
setzen auch hier in der kirche von
butscher das ist ihr heute gelungen aber
zeichen alleine reichen der ukraine
nicht
der bahnhof von grammatik ist der
östlichste der noch am ukrainischen
eisenbahnnetz hängt er ist eine
drehscheibe für flüchtlinge die
versuchen sich vor einem erwarteten
heftigen neuen angriff der russischen
armee in sicherheit zu bringen
dieser bahnhof wird heute ziel einer
rakete
die folgen sind entsetzlich 4000
menschen waren auf den bahnsteigen zum
zeitpunkt des angriffs die ukrainische
verwaltung zählt mindestens 50 tote und
fast 100 verletzt eine frau ruft
inmitten der zerstörung hier liegen so
viele körper kinder es sind doch nur
kinder die
grausamkeit des russischen krieges kennt
keine pause auch die stadt aktiv wird
fast ununterbrochen angegriffen und
sorgt sich jetzt vor einer neuen
offensive aktiv war mal die zweitgrößte
stadt der ukraine aktiv war mal das
zuhause von 1,5 millionen menschen und
ginzel ist dort
wir sind unterwegs mit der 127 brigade
der territorialverteidigung in hartz iv
vor dem krieg hatten die männer normale
jobs jetzt kämpfen sie für ihr land
die situation ist stabil aber sehr
angespannt immer wieder gibt es angriffe
die dauern immer zwischen 5 bis 15
minuten man hört wie die geschosse
vorbeifliegen wir sind jetzt in einer
gefahrenzone und warten auf das kommando
für einen grünen korridor damit wir
weiterfahren können
wir hören den gesamten tag schon
detonationen in der stadt hinter mir
sieht man eine riesige rauchwolke dort
hat eine rakete eingeschlagen
wir fahren weiter richtung front die ist
nur eineinhalb kilometer entfernt die
straßen sind menschenleer
viele bürger fürchten eine offensive der
russen haben sich in sicherheit gebracht
seit eineinhalb monaten leben sie in
diesem bunker alte frauen kranke
gebrechliche die nicht fliehen können
es ist kein zuckerschlecken hier wir
brauchen freiheit keinen keller sondern
freiheit
ich möchte dass endlich diese geräusche
von oben aufhören die angriffe ich
möchte dass der krieg endlich zu ende
geht
wir machen uns wieder auf den weg doch
dann plötzlich stoppen die männer am
straßenrand
in den keller in den keller schnell zum
eingang
sitzt in sicherheit bringen
das wetter passiert
dann die entwarnung
wir hatten glück aber die explosionen
waren ganz in der nähe nicht nur in
bunkern auch in der u-bahn leben viele
menschen hier seit wochen vor allem
frauen und kinder
mein name ist
alex ist 12 jahre und kann sogar ein
bisschen deutsch er zeigt uns sein
kinderzimmer in einem u bahnwaggon
ich sammle diese figuren hier und hier
habe ich einen kleinen baum alex macht
ein experiment er möchte sehen wie seine
pflanze hier unten ohne sonnenlicht
wächst eine kindheit im krieg in haag
eve
alex so zu einer pflanze in der u bahn
angesichts dieser bilder könnte sich in
finnland das mehr als 1300 kilometer
grenze zu russland hat ein historischer
kurswechsel anbahnen das militärisch
neutrale land überlegt ganz konkret
einen beitritt zur nato und gundula du
hast mir dazu
bundespräsident steinmeier hat finnland
bei seinem besuch in helsinki dabei die
volle unterstützung deutschlands
zugesagt eben auch für eine eventuelle
aufnahme in die nato gemeinsam mit dem
finnischen präsidenten minister
verurteilte er den russischen
angriffskrieg scharf das barbarische
blutvergießen in der ukraine müsse enden
kremlchef putin müsse diesen wahnsinn
stoppen finnlands präsident sagte zdf-
heute er rechne mit einem starken
parlamentsmandat für einen nato-beitritt
antrag
bei seinem antrittbesuch in london hat
bundeskanzler scholz ebenfalls erneut
ein sofortiges ende des krieges
gefordert gemeinsam mit prämie johnson
sagte er der ukraine unterstützung zu
auch in form weiterer waffenlieferungen
johnson setzt sich seit kriegsbeginn für
mehr hilfe für die ukraine ein fast
täglich telefoniere er mit präsident see
lenski
israel wird wieder von einer serie von
anschlägen erschüttert
ministerpräsident bennett waren vor
weiteren attacken durch nachahmungstäter
die anti terror maßnahmen wurden
ausgeweitet in tel aviv haben
sicherheitskräfte nach stundenlanger
fahndung den mutmaßlichen mörder drei
israelis erschossen einen palästinenser
aus dem westjordanland
es war der vierte anschlag in rund zwei
wochen
die frühere spd chefin andrea nahles ist
vom verwaltungsrat der bundesagentur für
arbeit als neue vorstandsvorsitzende
vorgeschlagen worden die formelle
zustimmung des bundeskabinetts gilt als
sicher im august soll die frühere
bundesarbeitsministerin im neuen amt
starten
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hat das
scheitern der allgemeinen impfpflicht
erneut als eine klare und bittere
niederlage für alle befürworte und damit
auch für sich selbst bewertet wegen der
verbleibenden impflücken rechnet er für
den herbst wieder mit mehr
schutzauflagen trotz aktuell sinkender
inzidenz warnte lauterbach auch für
reisen in der osterzeit zu umsicht und
tests
übermorgen werden unsere nachbarn im
westen und zwar zunächst mal ihren
staatspräsidenten oder ihre
staatspräsidentin aber sie wählen noch
viel mehr die französinnen und franzosen
entscheiden auch über eine geschlossene
europäische haltung gegenüber wladimir
putin sie entscheiden auch über die
zukunft womöglich das schicksal der eu
denn das rennen ist viel knapper als
erwartet ein weiter so von dem manual
makro alles andere als sicher
aus der stichwahl könnte die
rechtspopulistin marine le pen als
siegerin hervorgehen so nah an der macht
wie dieses mal war sie wohl noch nie
eine arbeit mit mir aus paris
momente in denen emanuel makro dem weg
zum volk suchte waren im wahlkampf auch
daher gilt der präsident vielen als
unnahbar nun wirbt er um das vertrauen
für eine weitere amtszeit und verteidigt
seine politik
meine reformen haben fortschritt
gebracht an dem tandem liberalisieren
und schützen halte ich fest und auch
daran dass wir ein system haben dass die
franzosen in krisenzeiten absichern
doch längst nicht alle nehmen ihm die
rolle des beschützers ab sie sorgen sich
vor weiter steigenden kosten für energie
und für lebensmittel haben angst vor dem
abstieg
ich habe familie bin 46 jahre alt und
kann nicht von meinem einkommen leben
finden sie das neue ryse youtube sonoma
zur kaufkraftsteigerung haben wir 20
milliarden euro ausgegeben
richtig aber ich habe nichts davon weil
ich keine ansprüche habe ich zahle immer
nur
und so holt marine le pen immer mehr auf
setzt auf die stimmen der unzufriedenen
und jener die den verlust der
französischen werte fürchten vor allem
auf dem land erhält sie viel zuspruch
mein gegner heißt emanuel maxl in
willich besiegen für frankreich
es ist der dritte anlauf der
rechtspopulisten laut umfragen war sie
nie
da an präsidentenamt sie gibt sich
inzwischen weniger radikal doch im kern
bleibt sie ihrem nationalistischen kurs
treu der folgenreich wäre für europa und
für die deutsch-französische
zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
entweder werden wir in einer
globalisierten welt deren vorreiter die
europäische union ist untergehen oder
wir stärken die französische nation die
die unseren schützt
und noch ein anti europäer mobilisiert
die massen jean-luc melo show ist der
chancenreichste unter den zahlreichen
linken kandidatin sein programm mehr
mindestlohn rente schon ab 60 und
austritt aus der nato er wird auf platz
3 gesehen nach marine le pen und emanuel
makro vieles deutet derzeit auf ein
duell der beiden in der stichwahl hin
mit einem sehr knappen vorsprung für
makro den reformer den pro europäer
cello war es ist der kampf des
fortschritts gegen den rückzug es ist
der kampf des europäischen patriotismus
gegen die nationalisten
in zwei wahlrunden entscheidet
frankreich nun wer als präsident oder
präsidentin im elysée-palast residieren
wird es ist auch eine entscheidung über
die zukunft europas
eine neue studie sieht frankreich in
einer tiefen politischen krise vier
fünftel der wählerinnen und wähler haben
danach kein vertrauen mehr in die
politischen parteien und rund 40 prozent
fühlen sich keiner strömung mehr
verbunden
gucke jetzt in der sendung noch mal auf
den krieg die sanktionen gegen russland
und die folgen mit gundula die russische
zentralbank hat eine senkung ihres
leitzinses angekündigt um die
auswirkungen der sanktionen abzufedern
gleichzeitig ist der rubel wieder auf
vorkriegsniveau gestiegen stephanie
berit jetzt ist die frage wie hart
treffen die sanktionen russland die
sanktionen treffen die russische
wirtschaft zwar aber die volle wirkung
wird sich möglicherweise erst
mittelfristig entfalten denn russland
hat ende februar mit seiner drastischen
zinserhöhung auf 20 prozent seine
währung massiv gestützt auch um die
inflation in schach zu halten außerdem
verpflichtete sie russische exporteure
80 prozent ihrer dollar und euro
einnahmen aus dem ausland in rubel zu
tauschen was ihnen ebenfalls stärkt bei
kriegsbeginn verlor der rubel dramatisch
an wert und erreicht am 7 märz seinen
tiefpunkt seither erholte er sich wieder
um gut 70% gegenüber dem dollar und
notiert damit sogar über vorkriegsniveau
nun sie die russische notenbank
spielraum ihre geldpolitik wieder zu
lockern und das obwohl die inflation im
märz fast 17 prozent erreicht denn auch
in russland werden die preise durch
hamsterkäufe und mangelnde importe aus
dem westen getrieben dass die russische
wirtschaft auf lange sicht schrumpfen
wird das schiff fest allein in diesem
jahr wohl um zehn prozent hinzu kommt
der hightech mangel denn der russische
öl und gassektor ist stark auf
spezialausrüstungen und teile aus dem
westen angewiesen
und wenn die ausbleiben könnte das die
produktion beeinträchtigen und damit
auch die energieexporte devisen experten
gehen davon aus dass der hobel trotz
seiner aktuellen robustheit doch
langfristig an wert verlieren wird weil
einfach viele konzerne aus europa und
den usa ihre öl importe aus russland
einschränken werden und damit auch
weniger devisen ins land kommen vielen
dank stefanie bareth gerne der
süßwarenriesen ferrero muss wegen
salmonellen fällen die produktion in
einer fabrik in belgien vorerst stoppen
schon im dezember war dort ein
salmonellen fall gemeldet worden die
belgische aufsichtsbehörde schloss jetzt
das werk ferrero ruft auch in
deutschland alle schokoladenprodukte der
marke kinder aus dem werk zurück
darunter überraschungseier
boris becker ist in seinem londoner
prozess wegen insolvenzverschleppung
teilweise schuldig gesprochen worden die
geschworenen sprachen ihn in vier von 24
anklagepunkten schuldig darunter die
verschleierung von besitz und schulden
der frühere tennis-star 2017 wegen
millionen schulden für insolvent erklärt
hatte alle vorwürfe zurückgewiesen das
strafmaß wird in drei wochen verkündet
eine haftstrafe ist nicht auszuschließen
und in der fußball bundesliga geht das
freitagsspiel in diesen sekunden zu ende
stuttgart steht da mit 0 2 im rückstand
auf den tabellenzweiten borussia
dortmund
und noch eine meldung in eigener sache
unsere kollegin bettina schausten wird
im oktober
chefredakteurin des zdf ihre
stellvertreterin und leiterin der
hauptredaktion aktuelles wird anne
gellinek zuletzt korrespondentin in
brüssel der zdf-verwaltungsrat bestimmte
zudem nadine billige bislang chefin von
zdfneo zur neuen programmdirektorin und
folgte damit dem vorschlag von
zdf-intendant norbert himmler mit der
komplettierung der geschäftsleitung
können wir nun gemeinsam am ziel
arbeiten dass wir für die ganze
gesellschaft ein ausgezeichnetes
öffentlich rechtliches programm machen
und das für alle aus spiel wege
ein neues spitzenteam für uns für sie
für spannende und herausfordernde zeiten
die künftige chefredakteurin des zweiten
deutschen fernsehens begrüßt sie
übrigens morgen hier an dieser stelle
das heute journal dann wieder mit
bettina und 4 gelang
und wir weisen noch gerne auf das
heute-journal update hin um 0.30 mit
nazan glückten ihr jetzt gleich geht es
hier weiter mit dem zdf politbarometer
dass sich auch wieder mit den folgen des
krieges befasst von uns allen sehr
angenehm
herzlich willkommen zum politbarometer
der krieg in der ukraine und die folgen
und die andauernde corona pandemie die
deutsche politik ist weiter im
krisenmodus auf die eskalation der
russischen gewalt hat der westen mit
neuen verschärfungen der sanktionen
reagiert was halten die deutschen davon
77 prozent der befragten finden eine
verschärfung der wirtschaftlichen
strafmaßnahmen richtig nur 18 prozent
halten sie für nicht angemessen 5
prozent wissen es nicht
müsste die bundesregierung noch mehr tun
um der ukraine zu helfen
jeder zweite deutsche findet die
bisherige unterstützung genau richtig
immerhin 37 prozent sagen das ist zu
wenig um kein geld mehr in putins
kriegskasse zu überweisen ist ein
sofortiger stopp von gas- und
erdölimporte aus russland in der
diskussion
28 prozent der befragten befürworten
einen sofortigen importstopp auch wenn
dadurch versorgungsprobleme in
deutschland entstehen der mehrheit von
54 prozent ist das zu unsicher sie
wollen die energielieferungen erst
beenden wenn weitgehend alternativen zur
verfügung stehen 14 prozent sind gegen
einen einfuhrstopp
der vorsichtige kurs entspricht der
linie von wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck die bundesregierung arbeitet seit
kriegsbeginn an der schrittweisen
reduzierung von energie importen aus
russland
doch gut die hälfte der deutschen meint
das reicht noch nicht und fordert mehr
anstrengungen der bundesregierung um
unabhängig vom russischen gas und öl zu
werden
als maßnahme zur einsparung von energie
ist auch ein zeitlich befristetes
tempolimit auf autobahnen im gespräch
25 prozent der deutschen sind für eine
temporäre
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung von 130
stundenkilometern um den
kraftstoffverbrauch zu senken
50 prozent sind generell für ein solches
tempolimit nur etwa ein viertel der
deutschen ist grundsätzlich dagegen
als krisenmanager kommen vor allem zwei
grüne bei den wählern an
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck und
außenministerin annalena baerbock
erreichen persönliche bestwerte
andere dagegen müssen deutliche einbußen
hinnehmen
unsere top ten der wichtigsten politiker
nach sympathie und leistung auf der
skala von plus fünf bis minus fünf
schlusslicht ist sahra wagenknecht minus
0,9 etwas besser davor friedrich merz
null komma null auf rang 8 markus söder
0,1 beide schlechter vor ihm christian
lindner 0,5 und karl lauterbach 0,8
beide stark verschlechtert davor cem
özdemir 1,0 unverändert auf rang vier
winfried kretschmann 1,2 etwas
schlechter vor eben annalena baerbock
1,5 etwas besser auf rang 2 olaf scholz
1,8 etwas schlechter neu an der spitze
robert habeck 1,9 verbessert auch in der
projektion könnten die grünen zum
dritten mal in folge zulegen wenn am
nächsten sonntag wirklich bundestagswahl
wäre käme die spd auf 27 prozent die
cdu/csu 24 prozent beide unverändert
grüne 19 prozent plus 1 fdp 8 - 18 11
plus 1 die linke 4 prozent minus 1 die
anderen parteien zusammen 7 prozent
unverändert
infolge des ukraine kriegs steht
deutschland vor großen herausforderungen
millionen ukrainer sind auf der flucht
viele kommen auch nach deutschland das
kann das land verkraften meint mit 84
prozent die klare mehrheit der befragten
und rein wirtschaftlich wie groß sind
die sorgen wegen gestiegener preise für
energie und lebensmittel
rund drei viertel der befragten sehen
die steigenden kosten in vielen
bereichen großes problem für den
wohlstand in deutschland
anders ist die einschätzung der eigenen
situation
34 bereitet die steigende inflation
persönlich große probleme darunter
mehrheitlich anhänger von fdp und linke
65 prozent sehen darin für sich keine
großen schwierigkeiten
mit ihrem kurs in der korona politik hat
die ampel regierung zuletzt kritik
geerntet die allgemeine impfpflicht ist
vorerst im parlament gescheitert und es
gab ein verwirrendes hin und her bei der
quarantäne pflicht wir finden die
deutschen den wegfall der meisten corona
maßnahmen trotz hoher infektionszahlen
35 prozent der deutschen finden dies
richtig
wesentlich weniger als noch vor etwa
einem monat
63 prozent bewerten den schritt als
falsch das sehen mehrheiten aller
parteianhänger so nur die anhänger der
fdp und der afg sind überwiegend für die
lockerungen
die meisten deutschen bleiben auch
freiwillig vorsichtig vier von fünf
befragten wollen in innenräumen weiter
maske tragen besonders viele im alter ab
60 jahren aber auch 73 prozent der 18
bis 34 jährigen
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zf heute app und auf zdf heute.de
wie die repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer zdf de vielen dank für
ihr interesse das nächste politbarometer
gibt es am 29 april
und nach dem wetter geht's hier weiter
mit der heute-show ihnen noch einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir schauen zurück
in den märz und er war europaweit sehr
unterschiedlich temperierte und zwar
zeigen die roten farben wo ist deutlich
zu warm war zum beispiel skandinavien
bis nach spitzbergen hoch zu kalt
richtung osten europas und in den süden
solche extremen gegensätze entstehen
dann wenn die wetterlage ähnlich ist
oder teilweise stecken bleibt ja und
global betrachtet war es der
fünftwärmste märz bisher und im
vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit ist
die abweichung 1,1 bis 1,2 grad wir
schauen aufs wetter da haben wir es noch
mit regen und schnee zu tun in den
nächsten stunden aber morgen kommt kalte
luft von nordwesten her und dann bilden
sich schauer und gewitter das hoch im
westen bringt uns dann sonnenschein für
die kommende woche in der nacht ist es
sehr durchwachsen im süden mit regen und
sturm in der mitte fällt schnee
teilweise bis zu zehn zentimeter in den
mittelgebirgen und der schnee geht auch
bis in tiefe lagen runter und im norden
in den frühstunden gewitter temperaturen
dazu minus ein grad in der eifel und 5
grad in bayern morgen tagesverlauf also
schauer und gewitter die nach südosten
ziehen ansonsten im südwesten schon mal
hoher luftdruck mit sonnenschein das bei
höchsten temperaturen von vier bis elf
grad die nächsten tage am sonntag noch
schauer bei maximal werden bis 13 grad
montag bis 19 mit sonnenschein und
dienstag bis 22 grad ein schöner abend